bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur public
sénat dans quelques instants vous allez
pouvoir suivre la suite de l'examen du
projet de loi hôpital patients santé et
territoires à mes côtés pour en parler
le rapporteur de ce texte alain milon
bonjour alors aujourd'hui les sénateurs
vont discuter de cet article 6 sur les
pouvoirs des directeurs on entend
énormément de choses est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire dans le texte qui a été
amendé en commission ce qui est prévu
concernant les pouvoirs du directeur
c'est vrai qu'on entend beaucoup parler
d'eux des pouvoirs du directeur on
entend beaucoup de choses qui ne sont
pas extrêmement correct parce que pas
vrai ce que l'on peut dire c'est que la
commission a énormément travaillé sur le
texte et qu'elle a remis à côté du
pouvoir du directeur la possibilité pour
le président de la cme pour le président
des représentants du corps infirmier de
pouvoir négocier le budget les
investissements le travail du directoire
normale tout en laissant ce qu'il est la
volonté du président de république mais
aussi la volonté d'une dune
cette émission aussi important capital
tout en laissant la dette tout en
échange décision au directeur mais avec
une concertation très approfondie et la
possibilité pour le présidentiable de
discuter de l'ensemble des projets du
rectum
donc on revient à une direction
davantage collégiale c'est simple je je
je ne pense pas que le thème de
collégiale sur le terme approprié
il y a un directeur il y à un directoire
dans le directoire ya le président de la
cme les différents représentants du
corps médical d'ailleurs donc je pense
que le directeur dirige quand même mais
le directoire lui permet d'orienter ses
directions dans le cadre de l'intérêt du
projet médical projet médical et élaboré
dans le diéri coeur le projet
d'établissement parole par le directoire
et le président de la cme surtout et le
projet d'établissement et ennui élaborée
à partir du projet médical par le diet
voilà un petit peu pour le font
maintenant sur la forme
un des objectifs à des révisions
constitutionnelles c'était justement
d'alléger le débat en séance
là on a l'impression que tous les
amendements qui ont été examinés en
commission ce sont exactement les mêmes
qui ont été déposés qui sont débattues
aujourd'hui alors c'est vrai que dans le
cas de la commission nous avons les
amener 1460 amendements et que le texte
sorti la commission était
particulièrement devrait amender
complètement réécrit complètement par
rapport au texte sorti de l'assemblée
nationale donc le travail de la
commission plus de 36 heures de travail
mais 400 amendements regarder et le
travail qui sert au travail de la séance
le fait que nous revoyons des
amendements qui ont été mis en place
dans le cadre de la commission en séance
double travail et je ne pense pas que
c'était au départ la volonté de ceux qui
ont voulu la modification de la
constitution afin de permettre un
meilleur travail de la commission
on essuie les plâtres dans cette affaire
c'est la première grande loi 105
articles 1200 amendements en séance
c'est la première grande loi qui arrive
avec ce nouveau système constitutionnel
et c'est vrai que l'expérience fera que
peut-être progressivement ceux qui
verront leurs amendements rejetés en
commission ne leur ne déposeront pas en
séance et ceux qui s'apercevront que
leurs amendements risque d'être jetés
rejeté en commission ne déposeront plus
en commission alliés causeront séance
manière à ce qu'on ait des débats plus
équilibrée très bien je vous remercie
donc je vous laisse retourner dans
l'hémicycle tout de suite donc direction
l'hémicycle du sénat pour la suite du
projet de loi hôpital patients santé et
territoires l'ordre du jour appelle la
suite de la discussion du projet de loi
par l'assemblée adopté par l'assemblée
nationale après déclaration d'urgence
portant réforme de l'hôpital et relatif
aux patients à la santé et aux
territoires
dans la discussion des articles nous
sommes parvenus à l'article 6 alors nous
avons plusieurs demandes de parole
monsieur le président fischer
madame la présidente même la ministre
mes chers collègues avec cet article 6
et précédemment notamment nous avons
fait la démonstration que malgré les
évolutions ou certaines évolutions
issues du fruit des travaux de la
commission
le directeur de l'établissement allait
rester est véritablement le patron de
l'hôpital sans avoir à subir aucun
contre-pouvoir véritable je dois dire
que cela si cela est vrai à quelques
exceptions près cet article 6 prévoient
une opposition à la liberté d'agir du
directeur la règle comptable
en effet madame la ministre comment ne
pas s'étonner que cet article 6 qui a
trait à l'organisation du mode de
direction des établissements publics de
santé
soit le même qui prévoit l'instauration
d'un mécanisme de mise sous tutelle
présentant des hôpitaux présentant une
situation de déséquilibre financier
alors cette intégration dans l'article 6
l'ex donc légitimement penser que le
directeur est libre d'organiser son
établissement
nous n'en doutions plus sans avoir à co
élaborés avec qui que ce soit le projet
médical et cela c'est un débat que nous
avons eu toutes ces jours derniers ou le
projet d'établissement
dès lors que celui-ci rentre j'allais
dire excusez un peu le terme les clous
de la règle comptable il est vrai vous
ne pourriez dire le contraire que cela
n'y changera rien votre projet de loi
jusque dans la rédaction de cet article
6 subordonne l'organisation de
l'établissement public de santé à la
satisfaction d'un certain nombre de
critères économiques à commencer par la
rentabilité
si tel n'était pas votre volonté
pourquoi ne pas avoir alors séparé cette
mise sous tutelle de cet article 6 en
retirant la motion fait au respect des
attentes du ministère en termes de
réduction des coûts vous avez voulu
envoyer un signal clair aux dirigeants
des établissements publics de santé en
leur faisant comprendre que la limite
alors pouvoir était la règle budgétaire
d'ailleurs il sent que le budget des
hôpitaux publics soit en diminution
d'après ce que la presse rencontres
cette année pour 2008 par rapport à
l'année précédente
le déficit ouais hein
non mais ouais d'accord mais un sur le
fond les déficits diminuer puis en terme
de deux personnels et bien vous serrez
de plus en plus non non non non non
alors vous avez voulu envoyer un signal
clair aux dirigeants des établissements
publics de santé en leur faisant
comprendre que la limite alors pouvoir
était la règle budgétaire la recherche
de la réduction des dépenses liées à l'
enveloppe hospitalière et que le seul
contre-pouvoir face auquel les
directeurs de l'établissement public
aurait à connaître sont en réalité les
directeurs généraux des ars
autant dire le gouvernement vous
entendez donc par cet article 6 ordonné
au directoire d etat des hôpitaux de
prendre d'abord et avant tout les
mesures nécessaires pour leur permettre
un retour à l'équilibré le plus
rapidement possible
tout cela nous renvoie immanquablement
discussions que nous avons déjà eu sur
la subordination du médical ou
comptables sur la multiplication des
suppressions de postes sur
l'accélération des externalisations
notamment des prestations de services
j'irai même plus loin puisque je
considère qu'en pratiquant de la sorte
en faisant du respect des règles
comptables la priorité du de l'action
des directeurs d'établissements publics
de santé
vous allez nécessairement les
contraindre à fermer certains services
non rentables à cesser la pratique de
certains soins pas assez rémunérateur en
somme et pour que cela soit clairement
dit en ce début de séance demandée aux
directeurs des établissements publics de
santé de pratiquer des choix de santé
que vous vous refusez de pratiquer
madame la ministre
sans doute par crainte des
manifestations alors ouais ouais mais
donc il y a un certain travail qui sera
confiée je veux pas dire un sale boulot
mais ça reviendra un peu à ça qu'ils
établissement après établissement en
perdrons des choix dans les missions de
service public et s'appliqueront
demain un l'amoindrissement du service
public que ne vous que vous ne voulez
pas assumer et c'est pour cela que nous
voterons contre cet amendement est que
nous déposerons un amendement de
suppression
merci madame ministre la parole est à
monsieur jean pierre sueur
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre mes chers collègues je
souhaitais à l'occasion de cet article 6
aborder la question des centres
hospitaliers régionaux qui ne sont pas
des centres hospitaliers universitaires
en effet vous savez madame la ministre
qu'il existe trois établissements dans
notre pays qui sont dans ce cas il
s'agit il s'agit des centres
hospitaliers régionaux d'orléans de metz
et de la réunion j'ai été saisi par de
nombreux médecins tout particulièrement
du centre hospitalier régional d'orléans
qui ont été eux est mis devant le fait
que dans le texte du projet de loi tel
qu'il a été adopté par l'assemblée
nationale est telle qu'il est arrivé au
sénat les centres hospitaliers régionaux
ne sont nulle part mentionné de manière
explicite
certes il est question des centres
hospitaliers ayant une compétence
régionale locale etc départementale mais
il n'est pas question des chr alors
madame gisèle printz notre collègue
préoccuper également par la même
question en sa qualité de sénatrice de
la moselle et moi même avons déposé deux
amendements
le premier a été déposée devant la
commission des affaires sociales
et monsieur le président de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur nous
vous remercions avec les collègues de
cette commission d'avoir bien voulu
l'adopter il s'agit des modalités de
nomination du directeur
en effet nous pensons que les modalités
de nomination des directeurs des chu
doivent s'appliquer de la même manière
aux directeurs des chr qui ne sont pas
chez nous allons déposer tout à l'heure
un autre amendement à l'initiative de
madame prins et de moi-même et de nos
autres collègues pour demander que pour
ce qui est de la composition du
directoire
les trois chr qui ne sont pas pu
bénéficient de la même composition que
eux les centres hospitaliers
universitaires
madame la présidente mais madame la
ministre mes chers collègues il y a là
une question très importante en effet eu
les centres hospitaliers que je viens de
citer ont une action très lourdes dont
la dimension régionale est incontestable
je dois rappeler qu'en ce qui concerne
aussi bien leur personnel leurs
effectifs leur mission leur activité
celle ci ou ceux ci sont supérieurs à ce
que l'on constate dans un certain nombre
de chu d'autre part il contribue de
manière tout à fait significative à la
formation des futurs médecins
ils pratiquent des spécialités très
variés et dans des domaines de pointe
si bien que d'ailleurs la question se
pose
rituellement pour cchr de savoir s'il ne
serait pas souhaitable qu'il devint ce
des chu
en tout cas pour ce qui est d'orléans
j'ai souvent fait cette proposition car
je pense qu'il ya une logique finalement
à ce que des aides des établissements de
cette taille de cette importance et de
ce rayonnement
bénéficient de plein droit d'un volet e
universitaire donc pour toutes ces
raisons nous attachons bien entendu la
même importance que tous nos collègues à
cet article si ce pour les raisons de
fond qui ont exposé en particulier par
monsieur le président fischer mais il y
as pour nous cette question de la
reconnaissance dans la loi de
l'existence de l'importance du rôle joué
par les centres hospitaliers régionaux
donc je vous remercie vraiment mes chers
collègues si vous voulez bien prendre en
considération ces trois centres
hospitaliers régionaux
merci monsieur le sénateur la parole est
à madame annie david
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
l'article 6 de ce projet de loi temps a
confié au directeur des établissements
publics de santé un pouvoir nouveau et
donne de ce fait à ce projet de loi une
philosophie contraire à ce qui se
pratiquait dans nos hôpitaux depuis des
années à savoir que jusqu'à présent une
véritable communauté hospitalière
participait à la gestion des hôpitaux
mais cet article ne se limite pas à
accroître les pouvoirs du directeur il
vise également à réduire
proportionnellement et simultanément les
pouvoirs des autres acteurs de la
communauté hospitalière que sont les
représentants des professionnels
médicaux paramédicaux des ouvriers et
des personnels administratifs
quant aux élus le débat d'hier au soir
sur les trois collèges du conseil de
surveillance mâle largement éclairé je
n'y reviendrai pas nous nous réjouissons
pour nous pour notre groupe de
l'adoption de l'amendement
à l'unanimité les concernant néanmoins
une le directeur de l'hôpital sera donc
le seul maître à bord et disposera des
pouvoirs les plus importants puisque cet
article prévoit qu'en qualité de
président du directoire il arrête seul
le projet médical d'établissement et
pourtant vous prévoyez parallèlement une
disposition autorisant
recrutement de directeur non
fonctionnaires et n'ayant pas eu
l'ensemble de la formation organisée à
rennes ce qui tend à démontrer que pour
vous les compétences en santé publique
ne sont plus fondamental pour diriger un
établissement de public de santé il y
aura toutefois un outil qu'ils devront
savoir manier la calculatrice
le directoire quant à lui ne fait pas
illusion dans le sens où il est sous la
coupe de son directeur il ne disposera
donc d'aucun réel pouvoir et ne pourra
s'opposer ni au projet de contrat
pluriannuel d'objectifs et de moyens
mais ces pommes dont nous avons
largement débattu hier ni au projet
médical d'établissement ni même au
budget c'est à peine s'il pourra donner
un avis au directeur de son hôpital
car n'oublions pas que le directeur
disposera demain si ce projet de loi
était adopté du pouvoir de nommer et de
révoquer les membres du directoire
disant cela c'est bien votre
organisation que nous remettons en cause
organisation qui avec les contextes
économique et politique que l'on connaît
ne pourra comprendre et un organe de
direction absent de tout débat et de
toute opposition
nous avons madame la ministre entendu
vos propos et nous avons entendu nous
vous avons entendus ainsi que le
président de la république lorsque vous
dénonciez une situation de blocage
résultant selon vous de l'absence de
patron nous sommes conscients que
quelques situations complexes peuvent
effectivement existé mais nous
considérons que la solution ne réside
pas dans cette concentration des
pouvoirs et lorsque vous entendez
confier toutes les responsabilités et
tous les pouvoirs aux mains d'une seule
personne
nous considérons au contraire qu'il
aurait fallu favoriser et la
transparence et la collégialité
je voudrais avoir à cet instant une
pensée particulière pour ces hommes et
ces femmes qui chaque jour avec
dévouement et compétence en un service
de qualité
à l'égard de leur passion ils sont
convaincus tout comme les sénatrices et
sénateurs de mon groupe que vous ne
pouvez pas appliquer des règles
identiques dans nos hôpitaux à celle des
entreprises privées madame la ministre
votre approche technique vise à
démédicalisé la gestion des hôpitaux ce
qui est contraire à la logique d'intérêt
général et à la recherche de la
satisfaction des besoins en santé des
populations
comme l'a déjà précisé le président
fischer vous ne serez pas étonné que
nous votions contre cet article merci
madame la sénatrice la parole est à
monsieur jacky le menn merci madame la
présidente madame la ministre
là on arrive au coeur de la plus chaude
donc un compte
enfin de fond de votre réforme sur la
partie hôpital
hier soir on a pu constater comment vous
avez est complètement détricoter les
positions la commission des affaires
sociales qui avait été établie après les
discussions sérieuses et nous avions
nous-mêmes retirer un certain nombre
d'amendements de façon à faire que nous
puissions présenté en séance ce qui
pouvait faire consensus à minima sur les
conseils de surveillance
là vous avez complètement démonté je
dois dire d'ailleurs et défendu avec
brio ces propositions je dirais même
avec gourmandise j'en veux pour preuve
votre saillie contre les ondes âmes de
gauche dont nous aurons dans d'autres
lieux sans doute affaire l'anamnèse
puisque on n'a pas eu le temps hier soir
toujours est il que j'ai remarquée dans
le compte-rendu analytique que vous
disiez que vous disiez lorsque j'étais
intervenu je suis intervenu que je
disais dumas les directeurs d'hôpitaux
c'est faux
je critique le système j'ai pendant
plusieurs années était membre du jury du
concours d'entrée à l'école de la santé
doit chercher dans les candidats qui se
présentaient notamment au concours
externe de brillant élève de sciences po
notamment de paris qui ceux qui parmi
eux pourraient être avec nous pour
diriger les hôpitaux
j'ai essentiellement cherchait
effectivement à ce qu'ils aient pas
nécessairement lépine dorsale trop
souple parce qu'ils ont à faire face en
médiateur entre d'une part la politique
nationale il faut bien mettre en oeuvre
et aussi la réalité du terrain à savoir
les collectivités locales dans lequel on
a inscrit alors je sais bien que dans
vos proches collaborateurs ils sont
essentiellement inspiré par des penseurs
et je les dis lors de la discussion
générale qui sont des économistes
libéraux de la santé je pense notamment
aux professeurs le pen moi je les
inciterai pour laboratoire allait quand
même chercher un peu dans la littérature
north american par exemple sur la
sociologie et de voir les travaux qui
sont quand même banalisé et bien connu
dary mine superbe sur les institutions
sur les organisations et on verrait que
des hôpitaux comme les universités sont
des bureaucraties professionnel et que
ça recouvre un concept très précis en
terme de direction et en termes de
gestion dans les bureaucraties
professionnels ce sont les
professionnels en l'occurrence leurs
matières d'hôpital ce sont les médecins
et les soignants qui sont au contact
direct de la réalité du produit si on
veut prendre la terminologie du
professeur le pen du marché la
conception est complètement différente
quand on était intégré ces mécanismes et
cette conception qui permet d'avoir des
équilibres ce que j'expliquais aussi
dans le cadre de mon intervention lors
de la discussion générale ces équilibres
qui appelle la préférence
pour des régulations soupe pour des jeux
coopératifs dans lequel tout le monde se
retrouve
et bien sûr complètement à côté de votre
schéma de bonapartiste dans lequel le
chef décide le chef étant plus haut
niveau bien évidemment et les petits
chefs au fur à tuer said a piqué non
madame la ministre je ne pense pas que
mes jeunes collègues directeurs
d'hôpitaux supporteront aussi longtemps
ce modus operandi pour faire fonctionner
nos structures de soin aussi monsieur le
sénateur monsieur le rapporteur
vous avez demandé la parole et je vous
donnerai la parole ensuite madame la
ministre
oui madame la présidente merci père
m'étonne permettez moi tout d'abord de
la reprise entamée ministre mes chers
collègues et de vous saluer et puis
comme nous sommes en début de journée de
vous souhaiter à toutes et à tous une
bonne journée de travail
cet article 6 donc un a pour objet c'est
raté alors sept à petit pour objet de
définir les compétences et la
composition du nouveau directoire des
établissements pluie de santé que projet
de loi donne une compétence consultative
ainsi que les pouvoirs du directeur qui
devient titulaire de tous les pouvoirs
de décision de l'ancien conseil
d'administration qui ne sont pas
conservées par le conseil de
surveillance comme la commission larcher
qui avait observé qu'un équilibre des
compétences plus affirmée entre le
conseil de surveillance le directoire le
directeur offrirait à celui ci un
meilleur appui dans la mise en oeuvre de
sa politique pour l'établissement
notre commission a précisé que les
directeurs seront nommés par arrêté du
directeur général du centre national de
gestion sur une liste comportant trois
noms proposés par le directeur général
de la rs après avis du président de
conseil de surveillance que directeur
sera entendu par le conseil de
surveillance à sa demande ou à celle du
conseil qu'une décision conjointe du
directeur et du président de la cme
permettra
la mise en oeuvre de la politique
d'amélioration continue de la qualité et
de la sécurité des soins ainsi que des
conditions d'accueil et de prise en
charge des usagers que le président de
la cme devraient être consultés sur les
projets d'investissements concernant les
équipements médicaux sur ses
prérogatives du président de la cme la
commission a voulu inscrire dans le
projet de loi que le président de cme
élabore le projet médical
d'établissement qu'ils coordonnent avec
le directeur la politique médicale de
l'établissement
elle a prévu aussi votre commission que
le directoire approuve le projet médical
et prépare le projet d'établissement en
prenant notamment en compte le projet
soins infirmiers de rééducation et
médico-techniques sur la composition du
directoire la commission a adopté une
nouvelle rédaction mentionnant entre
autres précisions que les sages-femmes
ont vocation à être incluse dans la
représentation des membres du personnel
médical de l'établissement
elle a aussi intégré des dispositions
spécifiques pour le directoire des chu
en lui ajoutant deux vice-présidents est
prévu que la nomination comme la
révocation des membres du directoire se
fera par le directeur après consultation
du président sem
voilà madame la présidente en
introduction sur 2 puis 6 la conclusion
des travaux de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur madame la ministre madame la
présidente mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
rapporte le président de la commission
des affaires sociales à mon tour en ce
début de journée de travail de vous
apporter mes salutations unis veut de
bon travail nous arrivons à cet article
6 avec plusieurs volets sur la
gouvernance de l'hôpital président du
directoire directoire la nomination les
procédures de nomination et les règles
relatives à l'administration provisoire
des établissements publics de santé
je souhaite que notre débat soit
l'occasion de quitter les approche
manichéenne et simpliste se doit dire
que d'opposer d'un côté
je mets tous les guillemets du monde les
méchants directeur contre les bons
médecins est absurde
il y à des hommes et des femmes de santé
publique et je dois dire que nombre
nombre des fonctionnaires de haute
qualité que sont les directeurs
d'hôpitaux ont été très choqués ils me
l'ont dit ils ont beaucoup souffert des
procès des procès qui leur était fait
alors je dois dire aussi que l'hôpital
n'est pas une entreprise est qu un
directeur d'hôpital n'a rien à voir avec
un chef d'entreprise un hôpital ça ne
fait pas de bénéfices ça ne fait pas du
chiffre d'affaires sager d'abord un
projet médical car le projet d'un
établissement de santé ne saurait être
qu'un projet médical qu'un projet de
soins bien sûr il y a à gérer l'aspect
financier mais cette ses finances de
l'hôpital
elles représentent des possibilités
financières qui sont donnés par la
solidarité nationale
le financement de la dépense
hospitalière est une dépense financée à
près de 95 % par la sécurité sociale par
l'assurance maladie
avec 45% qui viennent de cotisation
portée sur les salaires 35% qui viennent
un peu plus de 35% 37% qui viennent
d'impôt d'impôt d'ailleurs remarquable
il a été créé par la gauche il est payé
par l'ensemble de nos concitoyens même
les plus modestes contrairement à
l'impôt sur le revenu et puis des taxes
affectées on pense en particulier aux
taxes sur le tabac et sur l'alcool il
est bien normal que de tout cela
l'ensemble des responsables au
gouvernement dans l'administration les
directeurs rende compte et rendent
compte à l'euro près car c'est de
l'argent que leur confient nos
concitoyens et l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens
alors nous avons
lors des travaux qui ont été dirigés par
celui qui n'était pas encore votre
président gérard larcher ou plusieurs
centaines de d'acteurs de la vie
hospitalière ont été entendus des
médecins des directeurs des présidents
d'associations des médecins libéraux
également des élus et bien sûr tous les
personnels médicaux et paramédicaux de
l'hôpital il est ressorti une constante
et un consensus sur le fait que la
difficulté dans la gestion de l'hôpital
c'était la difficulté à prendre des
décisions et que cette difficulté à
prendre des décisions et est aujourd'hui
le principal obstacle à l'évolution de
l'hôpital alors que nos concitoyens
attendent évidemment que l'hôpital soit
une structure dynamique et réactive
temps les choses évoluent vite tant sur
le plan des évolutions sociologiques que
des évolutions techniques
c'est pourquoi cet article vise à donner
à l'hôpital les moyens de mieux répondre
aux besoins de nos concitoyens
le pilotage des hôpitaux publics sera en
facilité par le renforcement de
l'autonomie du chef d'établissement
président du directoire le directeur
pourra prendre des décisions rapidement
répondre aux attentes des médecins qui
souhaitent faire évoluer leurs pratiques
passé des conventions adapter les
activités de soins et dans cette optique
le directeur a des pouvoirs renforcés en
matière de gestion
le vice président de droit de ce
directoire et le président de la
commission médicale d'établissement et
les médecins ils seront majoritaires
l'organe de pilotage d'un hôpital
c'est un organe à majorité médicale
sa composition a été conçu comme
resserrée pour garantir l'efficacité du
pilotage des hôpitaux dans les chu le
président de l'acm sera le premier vice
président ne sera donc pas le seul vice
président et le premier vice président
il sera accompagné par un vice président
doyen
directeur de l'unité de formation et de
recherche ainsi que la vice président
chargé de la recherche et nous pourrons
examiner ensemble les conditions de
choix de ce vice président chargé de la
recherche parce qu'il va être évidemment
à la confluence de l'hôpital et de
l'université le directeur pourra
également s'appuyer sur des chaînes de
responsabilité clarifier des circuits
décisionnels des concentrés au niveau
des pôles nous verrons tout cela au
niveau de l'article 8
globalement ce texte tel que votre
commission des affaires sociales a
modifié porte une ambition de
gouvernance unis et tout est réuni
autour de ces nouveaux outils de
pilotage pour susciter une gestion
médicalisée du fonctionnement de
l'hôpital
je voudrais également insisté sur le
souci qui nous a animés tout au long de
ces travaux de prendre en compte les
particularités d'organisation des
centres hospitaliers universitaires et
nous aurons l'occasion d'examiner un
certain nombre d'ajustements concernant
dans le cas des centres hospitaliers
universitaires
la nomination des membres du directoire
la prise de décision
les prérogatives du directeur en matière
de coopération les directs les relations
entre le directeur et le conseil de
surveillance
l'élaboration du projet médical en effet
il faut que le directeur soit pleinement
responsable qu'il réponde de ses actes
devant l'état c'est bien normal
représenté par le directeur général de
la rs d'ailleurs c'est bien la santé
bien une fonction régalienne et je le
rappeler hier c'est bien le ministre de
la santé et et le gouvernement qui sont
interpellés
sur tous ces sujets et le directeur doit
être en capacité à ce titre deux
délégations d'exercer son autorité
d'assumer ses décisions comment le
pourrait-il si il n'avait pas aussi un
droit de regard dans les domaines aussi
essentiels pour l'hôpital que le projet
médical mais ce projet médical
il est évidemment élaboré par la
communauté médicale
le président de la commission médicale
d'établissement est une haute autorité
médicale il est au coeur du dispositif
et
il ne faut pas que évidemment de penser
à destituer le président de la cme de
son rôle personne n'y pense
et cela affaiblirait l'hôpital le
président de la cme assure la continuité
et la cohérence du projet médical
il n'a pas se trouver en position
d'autorité par rapport à ses pairs ils
l'ont élu il a un statut très
particulier son autorité morale sera
d'autant plus grande qu'il sera libre
les décision d'autorité seront elles
assuré par le directeur et ces questions
seront au coeur de notre débat le projet
de loi modifie le mode de désignation
des directeurs des hôpitaux tous les
directeurs des centres hospitaliers
régionaux pour répondre à la question de
monsieur sueur et universitaire donc des
centres hospitaliers régionaux et
universitaires seront désormais nommés
par décret pris en conseil des ministres
sur rapport des ministres concernés
parmi les personnels hospitalo
universitaires ou les fonctionnaires
hospitaliers ou contractuels ayant
validé des modalités de cursus coma il
ne s'agit pas évidemment de prendre dans
ce cadre des hommes ou des femmes qui
n'auraient pas des formations pointues
en matière de santé publique
c'est tout à fait tout à fait important
les directeurs des autres hôpitaux le
seront par le directeur général du
centre national de gestion sur
proposition d'une liste de trois noms
par le directeur général de l'agencé
régionale de santé
et après avoir recueilli l'avis du
président du conseil de surveillance
notre commission des affaires sociales a
proposé d'unifier le mode de désignation
des directeurs d'établissements qu'il
soit membre ou non d'une communauté
hospitalière de territoire et ses
mesures qui ont été présentés par votre
rapporteur sont une étape importante
dans la démarche de modernisation des
hôpitaux que j'entends vous proposer
je souhaite aller plus loin sur certains
points et vous présenterai au nom du
gouvernement
quelques amendements alors volé trois
l'administration provisoire des hôpitaux
les dispositions relatives à la mise
sous administration provisoire qui ont
été adoptés d'ailleurs
dans la loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour 2009 ont été
disjointe par la suite par le conseil
constitutionnel au motif qu'elle n'avait
pas d'effet ou du moins a dit le conseil
constitutionnel
un effet trop plein direct sur les
dépenses des régimes d'assurance maladie
pourtant ces dispositions étaient
capitales et afin de remédier aux
situations de déséquilibre ou de danger
pour la santé constatées dans certains
hôpitaux la procédure introduite ici
permettrait rapidement au directeur de
l'agencé régionale de santé permet un
processus en plusieurs phases sur
lesquels nous aurons l'occasion de
revenir
c'est évidemment une procédure très
exceptionnel précédé d'un certain nombre
de procédures de mise en alerte bien
entendu et cette procédure permet de
sortir d'une situation de crise et
d'assainir la situation d'établissement
pour permettre à un nouveau directeur de
prendre ses fonctions dans un cadre
stabiliser voilà mesdames messieurs cet
article très important je voulais redire
ce que j'ai toujours dit le projet d'un
hôpital projets stratégiques ne peut
être qu'un projet médical élaboré par la
communauté médicale
porté par le directeur responsable de
mettre en oeuvre ce projet médical
je remarque d'ailleurs que dans les
fêtes très souvent par tout le temps
mais très souvent le directeur et le
président de l'acm forment une équipe
unie c'est cette équipe unie que nous
voulons conforter
merci madame la ministre nous abordons
maintenant les amendements l'amendement
numéro 416 du groupe crc présenté par le
président fischer alors je voudrais tout
d'abord remercier madame la ministre sur
cette longue explication de texte parce
que je crois que vous avez un peu
exceptionnellement ça ne se fait pas
mais
et redéfinit absolument ou tout du moins
apporté des précisions ou apporter des
gages véritablement au directeur donc on
peut vraiment dire que cet article qui
définit les compétences et la
composition du nouveau directoire des
établissements publics de santé ainsi
que les pouvoirs du directeur aura
concentrer sur lui toutes les
oppositions de la communauté
hospitalière
j'en veux pour preuve le succès
renouvelé hier des manifestations de
praticiens et de personnel non j étais
alors j'ai bien pu juger de mes propres
yeux un donc madame la ministre les
quelques concessions faites aux médecins
de chu sur ce qu'il est convenu
d'appeler la gouvernance de l'hôpital
que le président de la république vous a
demandé de traduire immédiatement en
amendements n'ont rien changé sur le
fond chacun a bien compris qu avec ces
amendements la de dernière minute vous
ne renonciez pas à mettre en place que
le mouvement de défense de l'hôpital
public n'hésite pas à qualifier sur le
site de pouvoir vertical politisé détenu
par les directeurs des agences
régionales de santé dont la seule
finalité sera l' équilibre budgétaire
fin de citation ce n'est pas moi qui le
dit la façon dont vous prétendez
réformer mais je partage ce point de vue
là façon dont vous prétendez réformer la
direction et la gestion des hôpitaux ne
permettrait pas de répondre à l'objectif
que vous affichiez d'améliorer la
qualité et la sécurité des soins en
effet cette concentration de pouvoirs
entre les mains du seul directeur d'un
établissement hospitalier procède d'une
vision étroitement budgétaire comptable
et pour tout dire managériale de l'opic
le public elle ne recherche ni la vie ni
l'adhésion de ceux qui ont pour vocation
et seule préoccupation de soigner du
mieux possible des personnes qui
souffrent alors bien sûr ça ne se
passera pas tout à fait comme je le dis
mais sur le fond les objectifs qui
seront visés et sur lequel on
s'accordera à vérifier les résultats en
fin d'année et bien c'est comment
finalement nous diminuerons les déficits
des hôpitaux publics et à partir de là
ouais alors cette vision des choses est
étrangère à l'esprit qui anime nos
hôpitaux qui pour bien fonctionner ont
certes besoin de moyens mais surtout du
travail en commun des équipes qui
partagent et qui adhèrent à un même
projet votre philosophie est tout autre
d'un côté vous concentrer des pouvoirs
aux mains d'un seul de l'autre vous
écarter la communauté hospitalière qui
n'aura et les élus mais la bande monde
hier à rétablir un peu l'équilibré mais
néanmoins on voit bien que l'avis
consultatif notamment du conseil de
surveillance s'est bien fait que nous ne
pouvons absolument pas être d'accord et
ça c'est le problème d'être réellement
associés aux décisions
alors cette conception autoritaire alors
vous dites c'est le pouvoir régalien de
la direction et de la gestion de nos
hôpitaux publics facilitera l'exécution
des orientations fixées par les ja les
agences régionales de santé
et moi je pari pour l'avenir que les
nominations des directeurs généraux des
agences régionales et bien croyez moi
elles seront faites au plus haut niveau
si ce n'est par monsieur le président de
la république pour que là on est
véritablement les hommes qui mettront
sans état d'âme et bien des politiques
qui auront été décidées pour réduire la
dépense publique et mettre en oeuvre la
révision générale des politiques
publiques
merci à vis de la commission monsieur le
rapport oui madame la présidente e bay
bien évidemment la suppression de
l'article 6 sna est pas convaincu la
condition avis défavorable madame la
ministre
même avis bien alors j'ai des demandes
d'explications de vote monsieur le
ministre
fourcade merci madame la présidente
un homme la ministre mes chers collègues
nous sommes au coeur du débat sur la
réforme hospitalière et cet article si
ce que je remercie madame le ministre de
la santé d'avoir bien préciser et
d'avoir bien rappeler avant notre débat
organise de nouveau pouvoir dans
l'hôpital et une nouvelle répartition
la plupart d'entre nous mes chers
collègues ont passé un certain nombre
d'années dans des conseils
d'administration d'hôpitaux pour moi ça
a dépassé 30 ans par conséquent j'ai
quelques lueurs sur la gestion
hospitalière sur les rapports entre les
directeurs les médecins et le reste du
personnel je voudrais dire que nous nous
opposons à l'amendement de suppression
pour trois raisons la première c'est
parce que on va pouvoir et personne ne
l'a dit et je suis étonné que personne
ne l'ait dit on va pouvoir arriver à des
décisions plus rapides sur le plan local
l'expérience que nous avons tous
montrent qu'il est très difficile dans
le système actuel d'arriver à décision
sur le plan local parce qu'il ya des
blocages faisant remonter soit au niveau
administratif départemental soit dans
l'est les grands cas directement chez
le ministre de la santé pour obtenir un
certain nombre de décisions et c'est un
élément de blocage permanent très très
extérieurs aux problèmes financiers le
fait de donner aux directeurs la
capacité de décider après avoir consulté
discuté fait de la convivialité de cette
série nous permet d'avoir des décisions
sur le plan local et dans l'intérêt des
patients que nous sommes tous plus ou
moins c'est quelque chose d'essentiel le
2 et la deuxième raison pour laquelle
nous sommes contre l'amendement est en
faveur de l'article 6
c'est que ça donne au président de la
commission médicale d'établissement un
rôle précis un rôle qui va lui permettre
de travailler avec le directeur et dans
le cadre des chu on ajoutera la
dimension recherche et la dimension
universitaire qui est tout à fait
essentiel et je crois que si un certain
nombre de deux médecins qui défilent ou
qui ont défilé hier se pose à ce genre
de choses c'est parce que nous adorons
dans ce pays les conflits entre telle et
telle les batailles sur le nombre de
lits les querelles sur le projet médical
et que je pense que par cette mecque ce
mécanisme de de cohésion obligatoire au
niveau du directoire nous arriverons à
régler un certain nombre de problèmes
et puis enfin en troisième lieu je crois
que dans le texte qui nous est soumis
l'organisation conseil de surveillance
directoire permet de faire le départ
entre la stratégie le contrôle de
l'activité la prospective et long terme
et d'autre part la gestion quotidienne
de l'ensemble hospitalier
je crois que c'est quelque chose qui est
tout à fait important et auquel les élus
du premier collège des personnalités
qualifiées du troisième et les membres
du personnel notamment les directeurs de
soins infirmiers les sages femmes et les
représentants du personnel attachons
beaucoup d'importance
moi je crois que cet article 6 est un
article essentiel la ministre
le rapporteur de la commission l'on dit
par conséquent le groupe ump unanime
votre rat contre l'amendement qui nous
est proposé la parole est à monsieur
bernard cazeau oui mais la présidente un
ministre je voudrais chers collègues
expliquer aussi notre positionnement par
rapport à cette proposition du groupe
crc de guy fischer bon je crois que
manifestement il faut le dire la
ministre vous avez très bien expliqué la
procédure et vous l'avez même atténuée
dans vos explications
manifestement cet article est le noeud
ou une lap le plus important de la
contestation qui s'est fait jour parmi
les médecins
je dirais même que ce soit les médecins
de haute notoriété comme les grands
patrons que les médecins de base parce
que ces médecins de base on les a
peut-être moins vu dans la rue notamment
en province mais je dirais que pour la
première fois sa bail pour la première
fois après vingt ans de présence à la
tête du conseil général de la dordogne
j'ai reçu une pétition de tous les
médecins de l'hôpital de périgueux tous
sans exception on ne peut pas dire
qu'ils soient tous deux formations et de
tendance politique identique à la mienne
loin de là
donc je crois que effectivement ce qui
est important dans ces pratiques c'est
d'éviter la démesure
il ya des bonnes choses c'est vrai mais
il faut éviter la démesure et la
démesure vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
dans la plaque très grande majorité des
câbles médecin
président de la commission médicale
consulter d'établissement et directeur
d'hôpital sont la main dans la main
c'est vrai dans un certain nombre de cas
nous accorder peut-être 40 à 50 % et
encore mais très souvent lorsque ce
n'est pas le cas attention cette heure
nous parle eh bien les médecins ont
tendance pris par leur métier ont
tendance à aller vers le renoncement et
ils ne se battent plus est il du bon
mais si c'est comme ça nous on va
continuer à soigner
et puis on se battra que sur vraiment si
ça va trop loin et c'est ça le problème
c'est là dessus que vous comptez ou
comptait justement renforcer là le
pouvoir du directeur en lui donnant la
possibilité d'emporter les décisions un
petit peu par renoncement ou par
désespoir de la communauté médicale de
l'hôpital
donc voilà pourquoi madame la ministre
nous pensons qu'il faut revoir ce
dossier fort voir cet article
et nous sommes prêts et nous l'avons dit
hier soir même si ça a été dans dans une
ambiance qui n'était pas l ambiance
feutrée que l'on connaît habituellement
au céda nous l'avons dit hier soir il
faut dans la concertation
l'inconscient je tiens à dire et ils le
savent que le président de la commission
des affaires sociales et le rapporteur
ont vraiment fait un travail de grande
qualité
et justement dans cette concertation là
et malheureusement ils n'ont pas
toujours été suivies je le regrette
voilà donc très simplement nous donc
nous voterons la suppression de cet
article 6 si la parole est à monsieur le
sénateur jean desessard
comme il faut commencer la journée
bravo merci à tous vous êtes fantastique
travail excellent ambiance générale
amendement répétition capacité de
réactivité continuelle voilà c'était
hier soir bon mais madame je vous
félicite madame la ministre vous êtes
vraiment dynamique vous avez du souffle
vous tenez c'est pas une solution facile
vous montrez d'ailleurs qu'on peut
diriger dans des situations difficiles
sans avoir l'autorité obligatoirement et
en sachant qu'on pose et d'ailleurs on
pourrait penser que si les directeurs
s'inspirer de ce que vous faites il
pourrait y avoir des concertations tout
en dirigeant de façon intelligente
voilà alors la question est posée
vous nous dites ya des équipes unis bon
alors s'il ya des équipes une et là il
ya plus de dvd ya plus de difficultés
ensuite vous ne dites pas dans la
ministre il faut renforcer les pouvoirs
donc vous renforcer les pouvoirs
lebouc le conseil de surveillance est
resserrée pour qu'ils aient un pouvoir
plus important bond et président du
comité de surveillance soit on va avoir
plus de pouvoir parce qu'il est élu par
ses pairs donc il aura plus de pouvoir
le président du directoire c'est
quelqu'un qui va être reconnu par ses
pairs
donc il aura plus de pouvoir et le
directoire est resserrée pour qu'ils
aient plus de pouvoir
donc tout le monde a plus de pouvoir
donc alors où est ce qu'on en est alors
on va dire à son là tout le monde va se
sentir investi du pouvoir et où l
instance de négociation et vous nous
dites l'instance de négociations mais il
y en a pas puisque c'est le directeur
toute façon qui va trancher
et là c'est tout le problème 2 qu'est ce
que c'est aujourd'hui que les missions
de service public parce que la question
se pourrait se poser si on disait le
corps médical y travaillent dans les
hôpitaux dans des bonnes conditions
ils sont beaucoup mieux payés que le
privé
c'est quelque chose que beaucoup
pleuvoir les en valorisant que privés
bien non les conditions de travail du
personnel hospitalier
qu'ils soient médecins infirmiers aides
soignants et difficile donc si un moment
les gens ne se sentent pas investi dans
leur mission de service public ne se
sentent pas reconnus sentent qu'ils
doivent simplement obéir à des critères
comptables et bien ils perdent la
motivation et si vous voulez il faut
rapprocher sa de l'ensemble de la
politique du gouvernement
on a eu ce débat sur par exemple
transports collectifs et vous avez dit
toute façon faut supprimer les blocages
il faut supprimer les syndicats qui
veulent s'organiser
il faut supprimer cette solidarité
ouvrière ou solidarité de corps des
services publics parce que tout cela
pose des problèmes ils font grève et on
a je vous avais expliqué madame la
ministre
à cette époque que lorsqu on supprimait
la solidarité des corps non seulement
les gens se désinvestissent est de leur
travail serait déjà un problème
important
mais ensuite il n'avait pas envie
d'intervenir et c'est pour ça que la sq
il ya des agressions par exemple dans
les gares et bien le personnel sncf le
personnel ratp se sentant de moins en
moins soutenu par sa direction se
sentant de moins en moins soutenu dans
sa mission de service public et bien
l'estuaire et dire c'est un autre corps
d'état qui doit s'en charger
c'est la police ainsi de suite donc on
arrive à désert viste d investissement
global de tous les fonctionnaires de
toutes les personnes qui croient à la
mission de service public
parce qu'au bout d'un moment leur
demande des efforts sans avoir la
reconnaissance de ce travail de mission
de service public qu'ils assument depuis
des années oui monsieur autant monsieur
le sénateur françois autain
des ministres effectivement je voterai
l'amendement présenté par mon collègue
fischer parce que je pense qu'il ya un
élément qui n'a peut-être pas été
mentionné dans les interventions ces
rations oui mais enfin je te rassure
alors bravo - mon intervention aura cet
effet et elle ne sera donc pas
totalement inutile
non ce que ce que je voulais dire c'est
que 7,7
cet article nous apparaît d'autant plus
inutile que le gouvernement a déjà
procédé à une réforme de la gestion
opérationnelle parce que je préfère ce
terme au terme de gouvernance à la
gestion opérationnelle des hôpitaux
puisque il a créé ces pôles de gestion
il les a créés n'ya pas très très
longtemps et je crois qu'il n'a même pas
pris le temps d'évaluer les conséquences
de cette réforme qui a été plus ou moins
bien appliqué et qui a quelque fois
d'ailleurs entraîné à l'hôpital plus de
désordre et créer plus de problèmes
qu'il n'a apporté de solution donc ce
que je reproche c'est que sans attendre
de connaître les effets des réformes qui
ont été engagées
on s'engage dans de nouvelles réformes
c'est une sorte de fuite en avant qui au
lieu de répondre aux problèmes qui sont
réels que rencontrent les hôpitaux
aujourd'hui ne serait-ce que
effectivement dans la prise de décision
en matière organisationnelle ce qui
n'est pas le cas pour les prises de
décision en matière médicale
eh bien je pense que il faut arrêter
cette fuite en avant et qu'il faut et
peut-être parce qu'en fait une pause
souhaitait réfléchir un type le plus et
vaslui réformes qui sont en cours et
peut-être en fonction des résultats
honorables obtenus se lancer dans une
réforme plus ambitieuse mais avec une
une consultation avec les professionnels
qu'ils soient beaucoup plus ambitieuse
est beaucoup plus large que celle qui a
était faite à l'occasion du rapport
larcher
vous avez dit madame le ministre tout à
l'heure que
monsieur fait notre coller une président
larcher avait rencontré beaucoup
d'acteurs du monde hospitalier
mais je pense que il eût été préférable
comme vous l'avez fait pour
l'organisation des soins et aux vous
auriez répondu par là à la demande des
praticiens hospitaliers d'organiser des
états généraux est sans doute qu'il en
serait sorti des des projets beaucoup
mieux adapté à la réalité hospitalière
que cet article si ce que vous nous
présentez c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous voterons cette halle je voterai cet
amendement de suppression
la parole est à monsieur le sénateur
barbier oui madame la présidente
chers collègues je crois que cet article
6 comme il a été dit est fondamental
dans la nouvelle organisation de la
gestion des hôpitaux
je vois mal comment on pourrait
aujourd'hui aboutir à une réforme que
tout le monde souhaite sans l'examiner
cet article est intéressant parce que le
directoire tel qu'il a été constitué
avec les amendements qui ont été
apportées par la commission des affaires
sociales du sénat donne un véritable
rôle au président de la commission
médicale d'établissement et cette
majorité médicale qui siègent au sein du
directoire qui est un organisme resserré
puisque au maximum 7 et 9 dans les chu
c'est vraiment la cellule opérationnelle
qui permettra d'avancer et de traiter
les problèmes rapidement
j'ajoute que la présence d'un
représentant des personnels infirmiers
complète cette possibilité de
participation et gestion directe au
quotidien pratiquement de ces hôpitaux
et c'est ce qui manque un petit peu
actuellement dans l'organisation donc je
crois qu'il faut en débattre et bien des
amendements il ya une discussion mais je
ne vois pas comment on pourrait se
passer de cet article 6 de l'ensemble de
la loi bien il n'y a plus de
demande de parole je soumets donc
l'amendement numéro 416 au vote
nous somme saisie de deux demandes de
scrutins publics l'une émanant du groupe
ump et l'autre du groupe crc pardon la
première émane du gouvernement excusez
moi madame la ministre et l'autre du
groupe crc
il va donc être procédé au scrutin
public dans les conditions fixées par
l'article 56 du règlement ceux qui
souhaitent voter pour remettront aux
secrétaires un bulletin blanc ce qui
souhaitent voter contre remettront un
bulletin bleu et ceux qui souhaitent
s'abstenir remettront un bulletin rouge
le scrutin sera ouvert dans quelques
instants
le scrutin est ouvert
qui
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est clos j'invite mesdames et
messieurs les secrétaires a procédé au
dépouillement du scrutin
gfr
m
là
alors résultats du scrutin numéro 159
l'amendement numéro 416 à l'article 6 du
projet de loi portant réforme de
l'hôpital nombre de votants 341 nombre
de suffrages exprimés 340 majorité
absolue des suffrages exprimés 171 pour
l'adoption 139 contre 201 le sénat n'a
pas adopté viennent deux amendements en
discussion commune d'abord l'amendement
326 présentée par monsieur d'audignies
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues je voudrais démarrer
la défense de cet amendement par une
citation la tendance au renforcement
progressif des compétences du directeur
de l'hôpital est ancienne elle connaît
cependant avec le projet de loi une
nette accélération
le directeur président du directoire est
investi de pratiquement tous les
pouvoirs d'administration et de décision
à ses compétences déjà étendu le projet
de loi ajoute l'essentiel de celles qui
étaient détenus par le conseil
d'administration et quelques-unes qui
était resté l'apanage dans la communauté
médicale
il n'est donc pas étonnant que le
dispositif proposé est été interprété
comme un recul par rapport à la
recherche d'une nouvelle gouvernance
c'est-à-dire pour reprendre l'expression
du rapport larcher d'un meilleur
équilibre entre pouvoirs administratifs
et médicaux à l'hôpital
madame la ministre ce texte ne peut être
qualifié de manichéen c'est le texte du
rapport notre collègue me l'ont alors
cet article 6 a bien sûr pour objet de
faciliter ce pilotage des hôpitaux par
le renforcement des pouvoirs et de
l'autonomie du chef d'établissement
il concrétise en fait il est la réponse
à la demande à l'exigence du président
de la république je veux un patron à
l'hôpital
si nous entrons dans les détails
techniques le conseil exécutif de via un
directoire
le moins que l'on puisse dire
et que cette nouvelle structure apparaît
extrêmement affaibli cela a été montré
dans les précédentes interventions par
rapport à l'ancien conseil exécutif que
ce soit dans ses attributions ou dans sa
composition
notre amendement s'inscrit donc dans une
logique de rééquilibrage des forces au
sein du directoire
il nous apparaît en effet important
essentiel cela a été dit et répété de
sauvegarder la notion de collégialité
dans le management de l'hôpital public
c'est bien une des spécificités de ce
dernier d'associer la proche
gestionnaire et la pensée médicale et la
mise en place de ce territoire devrait
conforter et non remettre en cause les
efforts qui ont été accomplis par les
hospitaliers pour affirmer ces dernières
années le rôle du conseil exécutif
merci l'amendement numéro 417 madame
david le présente
merci madame la présidente le
bouleversement de la gouvernance
hospitalière prévues par ce projet de
loi est donc par cet article on a bien
entendu dans les différentes
interventions qui viennent d'avoir lieu
est au coeur du processus de
restructuration étatisation de la santé
et cela semble bien être l'un de vos
objectifs madame la ministre
la suppression des conseils
d'administration et les super pouvoirs
accordés aux directeurs vont de notre
point de vue à l'encontre des principes
fondamentaux de la démocratie sanitaire
à laquelle pourtant nombre d'entre nous
et tous les personnels des
établissements de santé sont
particulièrement attachés en effet la
transformation de l'hôpital en hôpital
entreprise que vous n'aimez pas madame
la ministre je sais bien est
inacceptable et antidémocratique car la
santé n'est pas et ne sera jamais un
bien comme un autre c'est même tout le
contraire et nous nous opposerons à sa
marchandisation que vous encourager le
directeur pour nous
doit construire et mettre en oeuvre la
politique générale de l'établissement en
composant avec les représentants des
personnels les élus et les représentants
des usagers
cette garantie est fondamentale pour que
la bonne gestion des services
administratifs soient valorisés par les
efforts en matière de qualité des soins
de la communauté médicale et la culture
de l'intérêt général porté par les élus
une approche croisée qui est celle des
actuels conseil d'administration est
indispensable pour faire entendre les
besoins de la population et celle de
tous les usagers leur remise en cause
par l'instauration de conseil de
surveillance aux pouvoirs limités qui ne
pourront plus faire entendre la voix de
toutes les catégories de personnel ni
celle des usagers et où les élus de la
république verront leur rôle diminuer
malgré ce que nous avons pu obtenir soir
alors que ceux ci contribuent à inventer
des solutions imaginatives au plus près
des besoins des territoires pour que la
santé restent accessibles à tous et pour
nous complètement inacceptable les
risques d'une hyper centralisation des
pouvoirs au sein des établissements
placés entre les mains d'un directeur
tout puissant sont trop importants pour
que nous laissions faire
le conseil de surveillance ne doit pas
être une chambre d'enregistrement des
décisions d'un seul homme ou d'une seule
femme mais élaborer la politique de
l'établissement qui sera mis en oeuvre
par le directoire et son président le
directeur de l'établissement
merci avis de la commission sur les deux
amendements 326 et 417 monsieur le
rapporteur
madame la présidente je voudrais tout
d'abord dira
mon collègue d'audignies je suis
persuadé qu'il a vu l'ensemble du
rapport mais prendre une phrase de ce
rapport pour justifier la cage et j la
collégialité c'est un peu osé
c'est sabine en effet mais c'est osé et
donc là que la commission a émis a
évidemment un avis défavorable à
l'amendement 326 parce qu'elle a jugée
justement que le principe de
collégialité est difficilement
applicable à la direction de l'hôpital
public et entre les deux amendements
madame la présidente de sentiments de la
commission n'a pas varié gouvernement
madame la ministre vo râble pour les
mêmes raisons donc sur le premier le 326
il n'y a pas de demande d'explications
de vote
monsieur laménie merci merci madame la
présidente madame namyst mes chers
collègues ont simplement quelques mots
un petit peu sur sur cette
interprétation parce que l'on sait ces
deux amendements bon qui est c'est vrai
qu'on reste très attaché à un mot ou un
terme est le terme qui est indiqué dans
le texte conduit on n'a rien du tout
deux de choquant puisque j'irai les
pouvoirs bon certains de nos collègues
parlent de pouvoir tout puissant d'un
directeur mais bon dans toute structure
il faut bien responsable un directeur et
puis je crois que là tout repose sur un
sujet sensible comme ce texte
bien entendu je rends hommage à toutes
celles et tous ceux qui ont travaillé
vraiment de façon très constructive
l'élaboration de ce dossier très
sensible et très très important j'irai
le le terme conduit honnêtement
je crois tout tout repose sur le côté
humain dans dentelle dans un tel dossier
je crois que les directeurs bons sont
surnommés je crois et madame la ministre
tout à l'heure nous a rassurés je crois
globalement et je pense que là il faut
faut faut rester certes vigilant mais
honnêtement faut faire confiance je
dirai au rôle des directeurs parce que
je crois c'est c'est quand même des
personnes responsables
et puis aussi qui qui travaille en
étroite collaboration avec les
professionnels de santé tout le
personnel je pense que là honnêtement
j'irai donc avec notre groupe ump donc
nous ne voterons pas non plus ses
errements de mon vol à merci il n'y a
pas d'autres demandes d'explications de
vote je mets aux voix l'amendement 326
qui est pour et qui est contre il n'est
pas adopté un amendement 417 qui est
pour même vote qui est contre il n'est
pas adopté un amendement numéro 546 qui
le présente monsieur le président
fischer alors avec cet amendement
eh bien il fait partie de ceux que nous
avons déposé avec l'espoir de permettre
le renforcement du rôle des conseils de
surveillance
non pas que nous pensions que ce projet
de loi est amendable
il est inacceptable en ce sens qu'il est
contraire à toute notre conception de la
démocratie sociale et de la démocratie
sanitaire etc l'hôpital qui naîtra
demain de l'application ce projet de loi
ne permettra pas de satisfaire à notre
sens aux besoins en santé de la
population
mais nous n'avons toutefois pas voulu
rester muet son conseil de surveillance
puisque
nous considérons que le sort qui lui est
réservé bon relève d'une sorte d'un
dignité c'est un recul sans précédent
qui témoigne de l'idée que vous vous
faites des personnels médicaux
paramédicaux ouvriers et administratifs
en vous écoute mais surtout ne participe
pas aux décisions
cet amendement vise donc à apporter une
précision qui nous semble être de bon
sens puisqu'elle vise à permettre au
conseil de surveillance de mener à bien
la charge qui est la sienne à savoir le
contrôle des actes réalisés par le
directeur d'établissement
mais comment exiger de lui qu'il joue
cette mission si les membres du conseil
de surveillance ne peuvent pas disposer
des documents qu'ils estiment
nécessaires et comment pourrait-il se
prononcer par exemple sur le budget si
le directeur d'établissement de leur
communique pas un certain nombre
d'éléments qui l'auront et qui seront
nécessaires pour rédiger ce budget
prévisionnel je pense par exemple aux
injonctions faites par le directeur de
l'agencé régionale de santé
et ça ce serait très intéressant de les
connaître
dans le cas de l'élaboration des budgets
prévisionnels
c'est ce qui doit commencer à se
réfléchir et bien comment fait-on pour
le budget 2010 sans vouloir être
polémique je voudrais préciser que cette
disposition que nous proposons par le
biais de cet amendement constitue à
notre sens une mesure d'équité
parallélisme des formes puisque le
projet de loi précise quant à lui que le
conseil de surveillance qui n'a qu'un
rôle très réduit dans la gestion des
établissements publics de santé doivent
fournir au directeur de l'établissement
tous les documents nécessaires à
l'organisation des travaux du conseil
c'est pourquoi tirant les conséquences
de ce que vous avez proposé pour le
directeur nous proposons que les membres
du conseil de surveillance cuisse pour
fonder leur avis est exercée lors
missions de contrôles exigés tous les
documents utiles si avis de la
commission
madame la présidente le texte de la
commission donne un autre sens
satisfaction à cet amendement
en particulier dans le cas de l'article
donc je souhaite que monsieur fisher
accepte le retrait la deûle à notre
demande de retrait sinon on devra donner
à l'avis défavorable du gouvernement
oui en fait la demande de monsieur
fisher satisfaites
je suis donc défavorable à son âme
ordinaire
pour oui madame la ministre va vous
répondre monsieur le président fischer
ailleurs l'objet de notre discussion
d'hier soir mais je pense que peut-être
aviez-vous quelques somnolence c'est
impossible
il est bien évident que le directeur
doit rendre des comptes au conseil de
surveillance contribuer à la
transparence du fonctionnement des
hôpitaux
le projet de loi précise bien que ce
dernier délibère sur la stratégie de
l'établissement qu'il se prononce aussi
sur des éléments fondamentaux tels que
le projet d'établissement
le compte financier le rapport annuel
d'activité ou bien encore le statut des
fondations spitz à dire que nous avons
longuement évoqué hier soir évidemment
la loi fixe un cadre général et je
veillerai à ce que les textes
réglementaires précises dans quelles
conditions le directeur doit transmettre
des informations complémentaires au
conseil de surveillance
j'ai également déposé un amendement
précisant que le directeur prépare les
travaux du conseil et y assistent il me
semble en effet essentiel de formaliser
son rôle de préparation des travaux
d'assurer ainsi la production des
informations nécessaires au bon
fonctionnement du conseil de
surveillance
voilà les raisons pour lesquelles je
suis donc défavorable à votre amendement
monsieur président fischer bien
elle a dix qui nous ennuie madame la
présidente
c'est bien sûr le président il dit
regarde bien
page 21 tout y est en haut mais en fait
il peut se faire communiquer les
documents et oui non même mais cela ça
pourrait être véritablement fait
automatiquement
c'est à dire voilà et non non non mais
si l'on veut pas bien écouté
est-ce que l'on peut véritablement
participer à un conseil de surveillance
sans disposer à priori les questions et
les documents quoi franchement mais
c'est le président à bout le président
fischer a tout compris de toute façon
parce que quand il est dit qu'il peut là
on parle dans une discussion d'hier du
conseil de surveillance
donc c'est lui qui peut se faire
communiquer tout alors que dans
l'amendement du président fischer s'est
pas tout à fait la même chose c'est le
directeur qui fournit à ce dernier tous
les documents qu'il jugera nécessaires à
l'accomplissement de ses missions sait
plus très bien lesquels puisqu'il ne
sont pas cités donc je pense que c'était
mieux rédigé hier et que ça donne
pleinement satisfaction
je crois que le président fischer
partage mon point de vue bien je mets au
voile amendement 546 monsieur le
président
bien alors sur le 546 qui est pour et
qui est contre il n'est pas adoptée 418
c'est madame david qui nous présente
oui madame la présidente mais au vu des
explications que je viens d'avoir il me
semble que là encore cet amendement si
sam est confirmée par le rapporteur et
la ministre mme semblerait être
satisfait puisque nous demandons dans
cet amendement que le président du
directoire communique au président du
conseil de surveillance dans un délai
fixé par décret et il est vrai qu'il re
soir c'est ce que nous avons adoptée
madame la ministre
puisque vous devez nous précisées par
décret comment les choses vont se passer
tous les éléments nécessaires à la
préparation des travaux etc etc
donc madame la présidente je retire ce
418 très bien nous avons maintenant cet
amendement en discussion commune
amendement numéro 51 présentée par
monsieur pozzo di borgo
chers collègues
j'écoutais la l'intervention du ministre
articles 6 et vous souhaite pas étonné
je sois d'accord et qu'elles jettent
sonné aussi j'ai été écouté aussi les
explications de vote de mon collègue
fourcade à propos de la suppression d'un
amendement de l'article 6 et je suis sur
la phase avec eux avec des lieux avec
lui simplement bon le monde médical et
au monde complexe supplément de la
commission d'affaires de la commission
sociale
mais il se trouve que quand c'est de
paris je me suis retrouvé pendant cinq
ans au conseil d'administration de
l'ap-hp qui structurent énorme vous le
savez très bien ses 37 hôpitaux 720
service va être me lire soixante dix
mille agents van ly médecin c'est
pratiquement 50% de la roja française
et j'ai vu comment fonctionner là la
structure de direction de l'ap-hp
alors la première question que je me
pose excusez moi mais là mais ministre
si et les mambas commission si je suis
aussi innocents dans ma question
l'article ci s'appliquera bien j'imagine
à la structure de direction de l'ap-hp
de l'ap-hp comme également j'imagine à
chacun des établissements qui la
composent je pense que c'est la logique
des choses
au bout d'un show pose la question c'est
une question jouer alors il est évident
que par l'expérience que j'ai eue à dans
cette institution j'essayais de voir
dans quelle mesure cet article 6
appliquée l'expérience que j'avais eue
pour pouvait fonctionner et c'est là que
j'ai eu tendance à m'interroger
et c'est là qu'avec j'ai eu j'ai suivi
un peu ce qui s'est passé à l'assemblée
nationale et que j'ai eu tendance à
reprendre les arguments de mon collègue
du conseil de paris bernard debré qui
était à l'époque chef de service quand
je te conseille mme samson ap hp qui
était chef de service en tant d'autres
hôpitaux traitaient organise et c'est
pourquoi beaucoup de mes amendements cet
article reprennent un peu ce état
d'esprit mais est évident que j'en fais
pas une affaire théologique c'est plus
explication que j'ai en fonction d'une
espérance que j'ai eu et je vous demande
aussi enfin et je ferai également ces
amendements je ferai beaucoup d'humilité
patiemment de complexe c'est un monde
difficile et simplement ce que j'ai
tendance à une première réaction que
j'ai depuis jeu plus ce débat j'ai
tendance à penser qu'il y a un peu de
demandes de l'appréhension de demande un
monde l'hôpital des hôpitaux de ne pas
dire de points à ce qu'un des grands
hôpitaux en province à lyon marseille et
puis ce monde extraordinaire que j'ai
découvert en tant que simple et l'uc et
le monde l'ap-hp qui est un monde uni je
crois que c'est une structure que
peut-être unique en france bien sûr mais
je crois aussi en europe tout de même au
monde
voilà un au monde et donc selah sue
permettait que dans tous ses amendements
je vais essayer de faire part de cette
expérience et cette interrogation et
j'espère que le débat permettra de
réponse d'interaction que j'ai alors
l'amendement 51 que j'ai je vous l'avais
devant vous
je vais pas voulu relire pour ne pas
perdre de temps donc je soumets à votre
collègue du sénat
nous avons ensuite deux amendements
identiques vous pouvez enchaîner
monsieur pozzo di borgo pour présenter
le 50,2 rectifié modifié je le propose
dans le quatrième phase du troisième
manière du texte proposé par l'ua de cet
article pour l'article enfin l'article 6
lorsqu'ils existent en les repérant
remplacer les mots lorsqu'il existe par
les mots ou à défaut du chef de service
voilà le sont rectifiées vi qui le
présente
il n'est pas soutenu où nous arrivons
aux 613 rectifié bis pas soutenu le 420
monsieur le président fischer on
souhaite insérer le mot conjoint
cet amendement apparemment
rédactionnelle est très important selon
nous bien entendu en effet il indique
que l'avis du président de la commission
médicale d'établissement doit être
conjointe à la proposition du chef de
pôle permettant au président du
directoire de proposer au directeur
général du centre national de gestion
la nomination et la mise en recherche
d'affectation des personnels médico
pharmaceutique et odontologique tout
l'intérêt de cet amendement est de
proposer une coopération entre la cm et
le directeur de pôle pour établir une
proposition de domination et de mise en
recherche d'affectation de personnel
bon ça se fait un je crois que en effet
la question n'est pas seulement de
savoir qui va décider mais plutôt l
inverse de la
vision hier archi cloisonné de l'hôpital
comment fait-on pour travailler la
transversalité et les coopérations pour
rendre un meilleur service pour aller
plus loin je ne vois pas non plus
comment un médecin nommé dans un service
contre l'avis de la cm pourrait
travailler avec ses collègues
bon c'est une interrogation qui a fait
l'objet d'ailleurs de débats le 421
c'est monsieur autun charolles
mais comme vous le savez la profession
de sage-femme est une profession une d4
profession médicale et disposent donc
d'un pouvoir de diagnostic et de
prescription je crois même d'ailleurs
que le texte qui nous est proposé
comporte une disposition qui va
augmenter 1 cette capacité de
prescription pour les sages-femmes cette
profession est spécifique dans la mesure
où elle doit constituer en principe pas
le fondement du suivi des grossesses et
la réalisation des accouchements dit
physiologie par opposition aux
accouchements pathologique actuellement
l'exercice des sages femmes au sein des
structures hospitalières ne se traduit
pas comme pour les autres professions
médicales et la profession de pharmacien
notamment pas un statut de praticien
hospitalier dont le chaos d'emploi
respectent leurs caractéristiques et
leur autonomie professionnelle est
d'ailleurs madame la ministre en
commission a eu l'occasion de nous
donner son avis sur cette éventuelle ph
isation des sages-femmes et j'ai pas eu
le sentiment que elle était prête à leur
accorder la transformation
cette transformation de leur statut
parce que les statuts qui régissent
aujourd'hui les règles d'emploi de sages
femmes hospitalières sont sûrs dont
dépendent les professions paramédicales
codifié dans le titre iv du code de la
fonction publique cette situation qui
tend à placer les s'acharne dans un lien
de subordination incompatible avec leur
déontologie a pour principal qu'ont
conséquence sinon de nier tout au moins
de mettre en doute un le caractère
physiologique de la naissance alors même
que pour la grande majorité des
grossesses heureusement et des
accouchements aucune pathologie n'est
avéré l'absence réelle des sages femmes
hospitalières peut être aussi à la
source d'une sur medec médicalisation de
la naissance qui peut occasionner des
conséquences négatives sur l'état de
santé des femmes et des nouveau-nés en
plus d'une inflation des coûts
injustifiés pour la collectivité cet
amendement a donc pour objet d'aligner
le processus de recrutement des sages
femmes de la fonction publique de sider
celui de l'ensemble des praticiens
hospitaliers
lequel fait également l'objet de
modifications comme je l'aï dit tout à
l'heure dans le projet de loi il est
indispensable de les intégrer pleinement
dans la communauté médicale à laquelle
elles appartiennent
naturellement dès lors le président du
directoire de l'hôpital proposera au
directeur général du centre national de
gestion
la nomination outre des personnels
médico pharmaceutique et odontologique
mais également des membres de la
profession de maïeutique où de sages
femmes étant précisé que le cng est
compétent pour organiser le concours
national d'accès au statut des
praticiens hospitaliers nommé et prendre
les décisions relatives à la carrière de
ces derniers gérer leur rémunération et
exercer le pouvoir disciplinaire à leur
égard cette nouvelle orientation dans
l'organisation des soins permettra de
mettre en adéquation la pratique des
professionnels de santé avec leur réelle
qualification
ce qui sera source de substantielles
économies à un moment où on a eu
l'occasion de le dire et de le répéter
les finances publiques sont exsangues
l'amendement proposé permettra ainsi de
mieux adapter l'offre de soins aux
besoins des populations aux évolutions
techniques et aux attentes des
professionnels de santé
vous venez de suivre l'examen du projet
de loi hôpital patients santé et
territoires tout de suite une émission
spéciale l'europe en débat merci de
votre fidélité et à très bientôt sur
public sénat